in our series three meals we travel the
different states to break bread with
voters and hear what's on their minds
this morning we take you to the
battleground state of Ohio which has a
strong record of backing the winner in
presidential elections its electoral
votes went to President Bush in 2000 and
2004 President Obama in 2008 and 2012
and then President Trump in 2016
Adriana Diaz went to a small town a
suburb and Ohio's biggest city to learn
more Adriana good morning what you learn
good morning well you know how it is
sometimes people shy away from talking
politics but we tricked them by having
some food at the table because that's
really what gets the conversation going
the Democratic primary in Ohio isn't for
another month but you wouldn't know it
we heard some strong and at times
unexpected opinions across the state
in the small town of West Union Ohio on
the edge of Appalachia
Mikey's family restaurant serves a
breakfast to a staple of loyal customers
I'm Adriana with CBS News how are you
our date there started with manner thank
you very well thank you
and a morning prayer but our
conversation on politics got straight to
the point I'm thinking the Democrats
don't have a chance why is that well
they're going the wrong direction for
one thing we're capable they're
socialists and this is not a socialist
country retired business owner
Kenny moles has been voting Republican
since Richard Nixon hi there but across
the room cousins Dennis and Terry grooms
were lifelong Democrats until they voted
for Donald Trump in 2016 while your hat
certainly our Democratic know we
followed him the more we liked what we
heard he has delivered on these promises
they say the president's boosted morale
for the American worker that's a big
selling point here this is one of Ohio's
poorest counties were both unemployment
and opioid addiction are high first they
give me biking then they moved it first
set and they moved to hasta Cod Terry
grooms has been clean for over six years
but he says his life is better now under
the Trump administration before Trump
yeah I'm not saying the minute I had to
get food stamps and stuff and after you
know I got a job do you credit the
president for the fact that you were
able to find work he kind of motivated
me I mean
[Music]
so we've left to West Union and we've
been on the road for a while now and
it's just been all country roads now
we're heading to a more populated area
in the suburbs of Dayton the suburb
we've chosen is called Centreville which
is fitting because the county is
politically in the center in 2008 and
2012 it leaned ever so slightly left for
Obama but in 2016
President Trump won by 0.7 percent and
at the famous restaurant boy was it
split down the middle
say Trump so I imagine your firm support
is and you're recruiting small business
owner Debbie Miller credits president
Trump for a strong economy and you got
to admit the jobs and come back but her
niece Samantha Danes who also voted for
President Trump no longer thinks he's
fit for the presidency it doesn't even
matter about the economy I feel like
he's gonna put us in a world war
[Music]
hi there gentlemen how are you good are
you at the bar entreprenuer Dave Papp
rocky agrees the economy shouldn't be
the only metric of success he's still
undecided there are still other issues
that need to be solved and the important
thing is that we have someone reaching
across the aisle and thinking about like
how are we actually going to get there
[Music]
from Centreville we head up to Columbus
folks of this County have voted for the
Democratic presidential nominee since
1996 so we've just arrived in Columbus
the state's capital and most populous
city it's actually considered America's
Test City because companies choose
Columbus to try out their products
because of the city's demographic makeup
we catch in a happy hour crowd at
Bakersfield Short North High guys medic
Isiah Taylor says he hasn't felt the
strong economy personally Bills get
higher
taxes get raised a little bit more and
that's more money on my part
Renee Holton who's still paying off her
bachelor's and master's degrees wants a
candidate with the plan to tackle
student debt I have these coworkers were
talking healthcare bills before we even
approached I know we both had different
things that we went through last year
and out-of-pocket it was like three to
four thousand dollars it was just very
eye-opening for me to see what a minor
medical event can cost you if you don't
have insurance let alone I mean I spent
several thousand dollars out-of-pocket
with great health insurance so it was
kind of a it was a scary wake-up call so
you can see why Ohio is such a political
conundrum we met Democrats who became
Republicans in 2016 and people who grew
up in conservative homes who want the
president now out of office but there
was one thing almost everyone agreed on
those for him and against him they want
him to stop tweeting we heard that many
times did you do that all in one day we
did that all in one day Gail chance to
sit down and eat enough Adriana yeah and
did you it was it hard to get people to
talk to you there were a couple times I
could see you walking him to table you
say CBS is good too same has it hard to
get people you know you have to be kind
of comfortable with rejection for these
types of stories a lot of people said no
I got a couple of you know stairs that
weren't so nice but in general those who
did talk had a lot to say and you heard
their opinions